c'est un site dédié aux activités
sportives culturelles et de loisirs le
complexe jean lucien vazeille de
vélizy-villacoublay va concentrer la
boxe les arts martiaux la danse ou
encore des sports collectifs tout cela
sur cinq étages et une surface de 5000
m² donc on voulait en fait que cette
richesse associative se transforme en
une richesse
des changes avec les associations
finalement qui se retrouver dans un lieu
où chacun peut partager un moment avec
une autre activité et tout le monde voit
ce qui se passe à côté ça compte de ces
partis y
son équilibre c'est de ces données le
propre et qu'il faut au sein d'un
ensemble cohérent réussir ça
organisé tous et tous ces espaces
ce projet un investissement global de 18
millions d'euros parmi les vingt-deux
mille habitants de la commune deux mille
personnes sont inscrites dans une
association sportive ou culturelle
l'ensemble
les activités de la boxe par son ami
mutuel
d'autres activités
basket
issu associatif d'avoir un équipement de
dernière génération
réaliser toutes les activités sportives
c'est cette infrastructure a été livré
il y a un an il a fallu trois ans de
chantier pour construire ce complexe